[Applause]
on a point of order mr speaker every one
of us has been moved by the bravery the
resolve and the leadership of president
zielenski
invading troops marched through his
streets
shells rained down on his people an
assassin seek his life
no one would have blamed him for fleeing
but instead he has stayed in keeve to
lead the ukrainian people and to fight
he's reminded us
that our freedom and our democracy are
invaluable
he's prompted the world into action
where too often we've let putin have his
way
he's inspired the ukrainian people to
resist and frustrated the russian war
machine
he has shown his strength
and we must show him
and the ukrainian people our commitment
and our support
labor stands for the unity at home and
abroad that will isolate the putin
regime
labor stands for the toughest sanctions
that will [ __ ] the russian state
labor stands for providing ukraine with
the arms it needs to fight off their
invaders
labour stands with president zielenski
with ukraine
with democracy
slava ukraine